probably unnecessary there's bathroom
set your luggage where are you going or
coming from I am oh you are okay right
the brightest thing yeah and I'm Stan
okay I didn't take it as arrogant right
from here you go in the airport yeah
direct well I'm doing a Nicki show okay
that's the mother show not to be like
she I came to you guys first that's why
we want the explosive yeah burn it out
here then give them some you know Beeman
we've never worked before jail we've
known Jeff rather we may have like some
good chemistry I hope so yeah so far you
so far it's crazy it's electric it's not
good it's not great so far it's okay
it's actually pretty comfortable
unnatural it's fine I mean to come in
and start and announced that we could
have good chemistry and just kind of sit
and wait it's not the best scenario for
creating let me try that again
okay no it's okay can I say the lady of
the I think it should be a crime to took
off on someone's stuff like I would
rather someone punch me in the face then
cough on my license and then give it
back to me oh yeah that lady yeah like I
could be in bed for a you know a week
now you hype a contractor now it seemed
you know to come right in off the bat
and do that seems like it but I'm
actually pretty normal
oh you know but to watch somebody cause
you think she correctly on your life
took away license and the thing she
coughed on it and then she typed the
computer gave it back I mean it was not
sticky and wet I wash my hands before I
came in here understand I wouldn't
bother me if you didn't but you're not
an all Israel no I'm okay with it like I
won't put my fingers in my mouth you
know you do meet and greets you shake
hands I'm like what am I gonna do if you
get sick you get circuit yeah instincts
but I probably would have watched the
license I'm thinking about it right now
you did right I got that spray in the
bathroom didn't you did you say anything
to her I said thank you rich boss you
know voices it is like a guy who will
say sir I've seen him do it to people
like if they've taken his coffee cup and
the guy grabs with a some ago could you
not put your fingers of my competence
shouted people online but I really
admire his ability to not like with
others him so he says something but yes
that's an Asperger's type thing yeah
rich is slightly autistic but I mean
that part of it is good because
how they learn someone yells at them
they go oh I mean how do you as an adult
not know how germs work isn't it weird I
feel like you at some point you must
lose it because every kid I mean even if
your parents don't teach you somebody in
school teaches you everybody knows germs
are bad but at some point you just give
up on it or you feel like I'm an adult
so nobody's checking anymore nobody's
gonna show me this show with a germ toe
no not at all okay we had no agenda oh
good yeah you tell me anything whatever
I do you have something coming yeah no
whatever it is you didn't do any Kyle
research no just I mean I've seen your
Instagram videos you're very funny I've
known you for how many years 12 15 years
long time the Comedy Cellar yeah maybe
more yeah wait more is it more I think
I've known you for 20 years it's
possible many years it's possible and
we're both hotter than you were when you
started we were eight when we started
now we're pushing nine I know I came up
a little bit I didn't know but the AIDS
thing yeah yeah yeah but you've always
looked good girls always like Kyle did
they well I do a thing what's the thing
that's like I'm I get like shy or
whatever is it fake yeah totally yeah
and I'm like like a I don't want to do
stuff they make a mess that can take
care of me I guess those girls want a
project
yeah I like it a lot there's a lot of
project women out there yes they want to
fix you and make you perfect and when
you're [ __ ] up there it really does
attract women to fixing you yeah yeah
right now I'm single though and that's
why I'm basically on the show to sort of
try to get something yeah yes and then
going out there yeah it's tough to male
audience believe me on fire get the
[ __ ] nothing well have you ever had
like gym where a girl thinks they're
gonna fix you and then they realize how
[ __ ] up you really are woman I've ever
dated yeah really if that's me sure yeah
they won't think they're gonna have any
of a geared you have they steered you in
any way sure yeah a lot of them have
changed me or I've had great regrets or
yeah I mean they've all impacted me of
course but I'm just you know my your own
demons or your own demons so it's kind
of hard for any one person you're dating
to fix all that [ __ ] up so yeah of
course of course difficulties but I feel
like you become so big on Instagram it
must be very easy for me when
I'm the king of Instagram you're the guy
right now yeah I'm trying to get that
out there the king of Instagram
I like the titles we just say something
over and over people like Oh even the
king of it right you want people to say
that about you absolutely that's fair
except I guess you disguised your face
on Instagram a lot so it might not be
the best strategy I got to work out the
bugs right right like be have my face
someone but if you're gonna use comedy
to meet women Instagram would be the
spot to do it there's a lot of girls on
Instagram yeah yeah that's the vehicle
that they like - I actually I mean it
sounds like I'm a player by doing a
steady relationship
are you a relationship guy yeah yes yet
I I'm not like I feel like I need to
cheat or anything that luckily I just
got any more were you cheater before no
okay no but my last relationship like
she thought I was a cheater
you know sometimes that just happens
yeah and you can't really I don't know
change their mind and she's would go
through my stuff and you should be a
paranoid woman yeah a little bit how
long we were sweet great but two years
long-distance and then she moved in and
then four days later I was like I got it
four days after she how long distance
was a cross-country it was no she was in
Vegas I was in LA and I I thought the
jealousy would stop when she moved in
she'd see I'm doing nothing I'm watching
Netflix and but it got worse and I I was
at Starbucks and it hit me like a ton of
bricks like I have to do this now yeah
and then right as I thought that Whitney
Cummings came in this is the Starbucks
oddly enough and she gave me good advice
she said you go in there you do this
thing and then you leave don't get into
a negotiation which I'm so glad she told
me because it became that was happening
I would have been there for how you
afraid you I would have been afraid to
leave with my [ __ ] that's what I'm gonna
say and I was like cuz I left and she
didn't leave it was like nine hours I
was I was homeless right and then I went
back and cuz she was like I left you can
come back this is like at night so I go
back lights are off her car's gone she's
hiding in my bed in the dark oh my god
you know like a murderer yeah crazy
person
so when John Delaney joke you know like
a murder so wait she uh if four days in
what did she do that you're like this
has got to stop what did she do in the
she I got an alert from my google now
can tell you like someone's trying to
break in oh yeah thing and then like I
went to the like take a shower and like
I put my phone like very specifically
just to see yeah and then I came back
and it was like turned a little and you
knew oh and I was like I can't pay I
just suddenly it was like this give me
my life I can't live like this yeah and
did you're trying to get into your email
account down yeah and my Facebook how
yeah did you ask for doing enough I'm
I'm flirting with writing you sure what
the [ __ ] started that like maybe she got
cheated on last time did you ask her
what is your yeah there were a couple
things yeah I think there was just that
was just in her and I'm assuming it was
in other relationships it wasn't about
me really but also uh she found like a
song on my phone like she did a deep
dive into my phone into like and so I
wrote a song about some girl look I'm
not I'm embarrassed about that well it's
nothing wrong with that it's not a good
no rose show and I wrote a song about a
girl no that's not douchey I just won't
ever do the song I don't wanna come on
but what was the name it was the name of
this girl oh we don't know her they
might know listen can you give me one of
the lyrics then even if it's not the
actual and girl sing a bit of it okay
[Music]
come on a little bit of a good voice you
know I I will not I'm embarrassed that's
okay use that tool of yours use that
voice if you had a piano here maybe I
play it for you we can get a piano if
you need a piano it's serious okay just
sing a little well just say one verse
I'm gonna evolve in there no I like like
right now on your stomach you feel that
I'm humiliating get it out about get
enjoys singing a little bit yeah I don't
have a good voice first off you do I've
seen you on stage a million times yeah a
very silly and you play the piano he
sits down and he belts up Beatles - yes
Lee I do very high end comedy oh I
apologize
you doing very important work yeah yeah
my stuff is different very important
work yeah
so you wrote a song about a girl how
long before you knew her did you write
the song mmm
year and a half it was and I was like
that was a long time ago and but but she
had seen like I had updated this long
but I didn't even I was even thinking of
that girl in order became a song yeah
and how did it go yeah like what the
update what you do oh oh yeah I think
this had the song write a song sing okay
no cuz it'll sound terrible and they'll
sound cheesy no well in that case we
don't want you to embarrass yourself
well what is the line you gonna say it
how about not even singing it yeah just
say the line you thought of no I can't
even do that yes I had to do it there's
not enough money in this room here's the
thing I did a poem when I was in rehab
it's disgusting and it's humiliating a
weird way it's not like comedians that
you could take your [ __ ] dick out of
right but it's this whole like no that
one is like that's who I am
it's a weird exposure yeah right and we
I've done it on the show and it's
humiliating but it's always good to get
it I yeah I would feel better when you
did it right you know yes and no I mean
I realized the value in it but it was
just it was awful I'll tell you this
when I was in college so this was a
younger so I'm a little separated from
this song but I wrote it up for a song
called I'm a little shy
did you just trying to get out of your
shell just I and I just wrote because I
never thought about the lyric or at the
music which one of the lyrics come on a
little shy you must know right come on
you're bashful double-teaming I think he
really is a little shy
that is the worst line who's at the
chorus yet I wasn't the last like I'm a
little shy look I read cheesy music I'm
sorry no it's okay I don't make you no
that's not my living you know my life
shy and yet you come alive on stage well
how the juxtaposition there huh yeah I
sort of working like a didactic
I want to know alive from this song
obsessed do you want to know the line
from I'm a little shy or from the girls
oh I mean why not why not let's get the
hit he's $10,000 in front of me I would
rather take my dick out we're looking
for an unusually close it is a weird
embarrassment though so she found it and
she and she got to enjoy the song yeah
and she how did she know you'd updated
she read it or she heard it just I did
online notes on my whatever iPhone I
just record it sometimes I'm a new idea
like I'll update like oh this would be
better there yeah I was on my iPhone but
it was like I hadn't updated in a year
how did she get into your phone she's my
poster yeah like she was very good she
watch him play as at the point of a riot
watching yeah yeah yeah she got how did
she ever apologize you know look I gotta
go therapy I'm [ __ ] up that's what
would the problem was if if she came out
like I'm sorry and she once when I was
breaking up with her she'd then did
because before that she would fight it
she said she didn't try to break in she
just would lie and my computer would
tell me like her name like that computer
tried to get into your computer and you
and you said I got your name here you
know I didn't like push it you didn't
know why you want a rubber facing I
don't know well I think it still one
drum like there was so much trauma I was
like I know why all this is happening
you're a little shy like you having good
sex is great other than that she was
very smart she's you know it was pretty
and all that and she's very nice a lot
of the time it's just this underlying
when someone feels and I feel it a lot
to like a deep-rooted insecurities you
just can't bring that into a healthy
relationship yeah and like we've all
been cheated on and cheated and it's
like it's it stinks and I've had trust
problems where I'm completely
untrustworthy and I've trusted someone
else who [ __ ] me sometimes you just got
to go [ __ ] it I'm gonna get burned I
told you massage therapist said that to
me one time I was cheating in a
relationship and I said I don't know if
I should leave this relationship and she
goes just realize this you're gonna get
hurt no matter what
anytime you get to a relationship if you
get married and you live a long life who
one of you dies you get hurt or if this
relationship ends whether you end it or
they end it you get hurt so if you just
accept you're gonna get hurt no matter
what you stop fighting oh that's good
that was great advice
what harassment jerked off on top of
that that's good advice
also if if you've sense like oh this
girl doesn't like me as much as I like
her what I do is I put them on the
toilet now what does that mean I mean I
sit him on my face like I imagined them
like that they're like body is making
diarrhea I go look deep into like the
physical what's happening in this
person's butt and then I imagine them
just like this if someone doesn't like
me and I'm right to get hurt right I
wouldn't do this to someone that I love
you know wouldn't dare shoot them but
I'll just imagine like trying to get out
like a really like nasty [ __ ] and then
but then this obsession becomes sexual
what yeah the other thing I do is if I
think someone's cheating on me I imagine
it's gross
like if someone oh if she cheats I'm not
as a tractor anymore as I am right now
and that's what it takes down my
psychological tricks on yourself and it
works it does work have you know this
person or not okay have you been cheated
on I think so I never caught anybody but
this one girl had a lot of dollar bills
and a stripper yeah we walked by a strip
club and she was like this girl looks
just like me in this video and you know
and it was her anyway but she
I brought her flowers one day she's like
broke up with me immediately and started
dating someone else I'm sure she cheated
on me sure in right but I don't even
care it's probably gross yes right that
disgusted me off enough to be not as
into them it does turn you off yeah yeah
could you forgive someone for cheating
on you yeah you could yeah it was
chronic no I would forgive them yeah but
I wouldn't date them sure Jim do you
think it's gross to find out that
somebody that you've been with is with
other people and maybe they're more
equipped than you are yes we know it
depends on how you find out like if it
somebody who's legitimately cheating on
you it hurts but there's also a dirty
side where I'm like I can sexualize
anything but that's just a sign of being
a sexual act you're such a like a mire
like what I what I was that good or no
disgusting but you're constantly turned
on with everything that's good but yeah
but it's also it's it's not a real
turn-on it's taking something that hurt
you and then makes you feel bad and
finding a way to live with it to jerk
off to it and be addicted with it cannot
help in that I could under find a way to
take pain and get more of a drug trip
out of it right right yeah it's
revolting I have a question about you
that relates to Jim's psyche so for me
as the king of Instagram I have a
question for the king of Instagram what
is that refer to yourself in the third
person as the king of it what the Tatum
Instagram thing is a king of Instagram I
want the king of instagrams take on
something well you're doing characters
whether it's who at whichever character
you're doing do you find yourself alone
falling into character when you're not
recording yourself when you're not
entertaining not really know if I'm
thinking about or writing something I
like my face I will start to like kind
of talk to the mic with the person's
face and stuff as I'm writing that stuff
but not like randomly I don't just
because Jim does he care chip-chip
person yeah yeah and Tripp Jefferson
takes over Jim's life we just really you
call it you but cow there's a lot of I
don't know if you do original character
I'm cookies are brilliant impression we
does a couple originals - yeah I find
myself just doing it but it's just the
way you know I'm alone he had a
girlfriend you know I'm lonely octa chip
is like you know just what do you think
the edges as chip yeah just it is what
no no not like that right just you just
kind of start thinking that way and
you're alone and you start doing it and
but like you Craig doesn't like just
show up sometimes who's Craig it's a
character it acts like this it gets
what's going on
i am i could see though how people can
become
like multiple personalities because you
do feel like I feel protected when I'm
doing character like hi I can go on
stage and like I'll go on stage as that
character and just bomb and it doesn't
bother me like on purpose right I don't
have some protection I think I started
doing characters when I was younger
because I didn't feel comfortably might
be myself yeah and then it's weird that
I do stand-up as myself yeah maybe
that's but you see do you start usually
in character no but I I'm Way more
comfortable doing that right because
it's like it almost makes it easy you
ease on because you got this wall up
before you start and then it's like okay
I'm already here I can I can do anything
you know and you're in school we trying
to fit in how's my way of sort of
getting in with people like doing
impressions and characters yeah looks
safer yeah just getting the laughs you
know they get a good laugh I saw the
girls girl anyway though you're smooth
like a frame not when I was in high
school and middle school I was I did not
get the ladies I'm gonna break it with
this girl by the way how long ago yeah
SEP and of August oh okay it's a few
months have you talked to her since no
oh you're not a keep in touch person no
when they're hiding no dark bedroom I
think that's a good but I'm not even
touch but unhealthy doesn't matter like
I've kept in touch with like I got blown
off really healthy people I've kept in
touch with [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] people
I normally do but this I the relation
got cut off like a cleaver so two years
why you said one day said [ __ ] boom
yeah and I I did that because I I just
you know you rip the band-aid off slowly
and the to it would've been this long if
I was in my 20s it would've been another
two-year relationship but it right I did
cut off so just letting seeing her now
it we need to get processed through it
and then I thought I would be friends
with her so what happened when you went
back and and saw her in the bed I went
first walked in my dog ran up to me and
I talked to my dog in a disgusting way
okay you make deep you know that kind of
thing how I go like you look at her
Stinky's I said that's my dog once out
of nowhere didn't tell myself like ask
her if she's licking her I'm not proud
of this yeah
I'm like I was like oh when I said it
right Shane was I said it it came out of
you and I'm alone with my dog who
doesn't judge me so that there's like
that terrifying thought like it's me
right that's when you own that's what
you want to be came out to me and this
just came out of my mouth I went tough
night she's in the next room oh my god
like she's probably tough inhaleand
tomorrow me fine right then I also
probably heard that it was like I don't
want to stalk this guy anymore did get
help because she for two years I hid how
I talked to my dog like she thought I'd
talk to my dog like yeah yeah so um yeah
I think she part of that probably helped
cuz she kind of you know left pretty
easily what did she say when you walked
in you just talked to her for a little
while she tried to call me like pulled
me into the bed and and I just hold me a
kind of thing and I was like no no was
it hard for you at that moment you know
like oftime no I I still feel conflicted
because I I did love her and and she was
great
it was just like too much drama and we
it was also drama in the sense of like
oh this is not gonna get better this is
like who she is and we're not compatible
this will never get fixed this is not
like okay if I'm understanding and I do
this she'll get it out of her scene I
stick it in like well how can I make you
feel more comfortable is there something
make you beat I tried to do that guy
which is was the wrong thing I should
have been like you don't go through my
[ __ ] ever again like I needed to be that
guy yeah
to make that work yeah but your
instincts are to like fix yeah
whatever's wrong I want you to feel
better yeah like I'm here for you like
we talked about
and that was not no look it's my phone
is such a cesspool right it would take
her probably she wouldn't be no
deep-diving
yeah it's like literally just putting
the mask on alone in the water it's very
easy to find my poor behavior yeah well
that's your just behavior that's your
go-to that's your default have you
gotten better do you think over the
years have you calmed down a lot yeah
yeah much but just put it's natural just
for the Aged like you know at 50 you're
not in the same hunt you were because
like all right I know you know it took a
long time to get the
Highschool I will girls never like me
yeah yeah I still go through that doubt
but I don't have the obsession with
always needing to do something that a
relief it is yeah but now then you're 50
and you're alone and you're like well
you know like probably could have found
a good partner five years ago yeah but I
am in hell do you know 47 like like when
my dad turned 47 I remember thinking oh
he's gonna die soon yeah it's 47 but I
feel young like I only one I probably
think he was gonna die soon 47 oh it
seems young now I feel young I don't
know I look in the mirror and it's like
I go I think I look tired and then I go
oh no you're dying
yeah slowly right yeah yeah body's way
cutting back degenerate
yeah any business you see guys die when
they're 25 it's like it looks so being
you know 50 or 40 cent whatever like 25
you die it's tragic
he was in this one if you die in your
mid-30s it's like oh my gosh it was
young you die at 47 it's like yeah that
happens right that's in a while yeah it
couldn't yeah perfect drug lifestyle
choices yeah yeah too much McDonald just
drop it's not that tragic it isn't I
can't die tragically anymore which is
upsetting which is tragic so you said I
can't be with you and you have to go and
then she finally just went okay I'll go
yeah after how much time you have to put
into you've gotten very good at creating
narratives in one minute Instagram who
are you talking to stories the king of
Instagram yeah yeah yeah the king of
Instagram has gotten very good at
creating narrative mm-hmm behind a 60
second videos I love it because it's
actually forced me to make things
shorter and I find it doesn't get worse
it generally gets better right you know
most what I think things are right it
wants to be a min and a half mm-hmm and
it crunching it down to a minute is um
has been really great
do you edit it down or do you just shoot
it and then keep reshooting until you
get the time right I do different things
like when I do the multi
characters talking to the I do look a
FaceTime thing I have to write out a
script and I'll do like the first per
think of Caitlyn Jenner is talking the
most I'll record that first and then
I'll have a script and so when I'm
pausing like in my mouth I'm doing like
the Kim Kardashian was like oh he can I
do it now sure and then when I go back
the timing works out I I couldn't
believe the amount of I was just
watching the comedians in cars getting
hotter
yeah yeah between Jerry and and Jimmy
Fallon yeah and I was like at first okay
great it was amazing I mean he's going
back and forth but I was like the amount
of shots and the directions this thing
went and everything like there was real
time yeah yeah put into creating this
sketch mm-hmm yeah it's my Waterworld oh
you did that yeah I thought it was
actually a real comedian because getting
cocktail
sorry I was I was actually thinking of
the the real show
yeah no no no no they wit codfish they
gave what and unfortunately they don't
make it to get the confident Kyle's
Instagram so Jim can see it because
because yeah I mean I you start thinking
like okay this is just a guy making
Instagram videos and then you go in
going like no these are like these are
60 second short films it's the third one
right there you think on Eric trump are
those very funny oh thank you it's
really funny thank you I remember where
I saw up it made me laugh watch this Jim
you're amazing that's an amazing match
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah
do you I mean is this do you ever try to
expand beyond the 60 seconds like go
like I need to figure out how to do this
you're just go I'm the king of Instagram
right so this is where we're gonna stay
we're gonna stay in the pocket not yeah
I'm not leaving the pocket I'm actually
working a show I got a I got a pilot to
do a show I don't think it's a where it
doesn't been announced but it's like
basic I'm gonna try to make that into a
show much or as possible but you could
just do 30 of them those a week it
should be easy I'd really good bill
marcher oh thank you nobody does Bill
Maher you Napo you people who write
songs like I'm a little shy or pathetic
okay because you get the essence where
it's like it's this tape that's a Bill
Maher the well it's this take that's
just kind of an obnoxious take but he
does it in such a condescending way that
you almost feel compelled but like okay
I guess I'll agree with him on it yeah I
agree with him on most what it says but
I'm also like I don't like I wish I
didn't like this guy yeah why are you
talking to me like I'm an idiot I I
think we were on the same page but I
feel bad you making me feel bad is that
McCartney you purple yes Paul McCartney
this is Paul McCartney on a masterclass
you knows master classes are the best
yeah let's see the Paul McCartney master
class writing songs is a match
little thing you know so they just fall
from the sky really it is cold today
about this little bit your mother Mary
comes to me speaking words of wisdom let
it be not that song from a magic put
temporary lyrics in like yesterday was
scrambled eggs to start blackbird was
[Laughter]
change it to be about the civil rights
[Laughter]
couldn't be less helpful could no that's
how it was hilarious that's all you need
well we got laughs though that's good
laughing in it so it was fine
did you get any when you're making fun
of Caitlyn Jenner for driving away for
driving away from her house burning down
was there anybody going with some bro
back and clearly you stop doing the
impression after that man ever again
yeah yeah have you heard from anybody in
that family oh my god she doesn't say
yeah baby they they made a video cuz I
did a video can you I don't know like
maybe just do it but make it make it do
it quite as here for he lives just play
go down sorry the other yeah and I'll go
up sorry sorry sorry
okay they want that one I think does
that say mad at you yeah I play that one
cuz they did a response to this one this
is Caitlin and she's talking to all the
Jenners portrayed all of them portrayed
yes Mike Kyle Dunnigan the king of
Instagram yeah
told me to check in on him Chloe you
should have done that now I'm mad at you
yeah yeah now you're making me more my
know you're mad at Rocco an aromantic am
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
the top page and then this circle one
circle lenses Kardashians in a little
circle yeah in God and yam is Christ
we got the whole setup the king of
Instagram is here you're not even logged
in that's so humiliating for a
humiliating I'm sorry I gotta go
I'm sorry King I didn't mean we're we
wanted to impress the king of Instagram
Troy look don't it's not your fault
that's choice fault
Troy you can't not be logged in in front
of the king of Instagram
I forgot my past oh my god how could you
Morty what you could just use Jim and
Sam show if you want
is this live can we edit this out Jim
live through one of the king of
institutions lie it's live ah [ __ ] Jim
and oh now we're in a different
Instagram now we got to go on the Jim
and Sam show Instagram Detroit your
Instagram looks really bad in front of
the King rain doesn't want you to know
it's terrible it makes us look bad the
bezel-set the King Kings already unhappy
now you got to enter a security code
that was sent to the Gmail just send
security click send security code
Gallo managed to play the audio my phone
thank God the king is here professional
operation maybe do we have the Gmail
open over there no I got an open and
open the Gmail the man's upset oh my god
I didn't want to upset the king but not
angry no today no being we'll be leaving
very short
don't leave king don't leave we're
getting the security code for you King
this is so stressful this is so
stressful Jim are you stressed out
no I feel very relaxed because the King
looks relaxed but the King's upsets the
King is very upset well then I'm
stressed okay that's right
are you giving okay Troy Travis is
secretly giving Troy the the six digit
security code I believe it's due don't
okay okay this is a disaster Oh fine
okay one okay okay
okay great seven six in front of the
king of Instagram what a [ __ ] and now
your pants the hell are you doing over
there Troy put up the cases angry no
rose angry put up the Kings Instagram
right here shame oh my god Rob you ever
seen anything like this in your life oh
[ __ ] look at your surroundings what are
you Shane there's this black box what is
that white box I don't know I put North
inside your genitalia is getting in the
way of a boatload of cash yeah the only
difference is your sister
somebody funny actually I think that's
what made you the king right there yeah
yeah yeah that I was anointed by the
Kardashians yes
they've never you never spoken to them
they'll be on that no you know no
because like a lot of people they get
super sensitive they're like oh well you
should just let Kaitlyn be Caitlyn and
you know don't reference the genitals
but I feel like every time Kaitlyn comes
up on the Kings Instagram mm the twig
the the ball she talks about her
genitals oh yeah goodbye to my pickle
yeah she I believe when she was talking
about her house being set on fire
she made reference to the fact that her
dog you know was killed
oh yeah I was up in heaven with her with
her twig and bass that track she loved
to play with ours yeah wait I don't have
any sponsors don't worry you don't have
sponsors no I make no money it's that's
weird
we're the king I know yeah I'm still the
king you got a lot of followers people
like the videos can you be a king if
you're making no money
sure how come no sponsors have come to
you and been like cuz you could here's
the thing if sponsors came to you they
could have the Kardashian sponsor stuff
Yeah right you would just be the
Kardashians or whoever yeah yeah like we
want the president to sponsor something
we'll do it on the king´s Instagram yeah
I I think it's commonly there's
definitely cash coming some point right
you could tell right I feel it I'm
pretty sure I'm gonna buy a Tesla just
assuming it's you yeah yeah yeah
pre-order god oh I actually did
pre-order the one that's the new one and
then I chicken down you said no well how
much was it it was because I thought it
was 35 grand
which you know is pretty good and but if
you put if you make it a Tesla and you
upgrade it it's 60 $70,000 yeah that's
all that's all gonna plug in who the
[ __ ] needs that yeah but you know what
you got the Instagram cash coming not at
the am i what if I get alone just just
on Instagram code
bankage essential on teleportation yeah
yeah look I don't know if you know you
know bank but I'm the king of Instagram
so clearly the cash is coming quite soon
how do you make money on Instagram it's
very difficult Leslie it gives you a
show maybe or Safari yeah I guess you
get sponsors on lots of people have
sponsors I met did get the pilot because
of us that's something hashtag add but
so you have to do when you see that
people like well hashtag add your their
post oh and that's how you know they're
getting paid for it okay well I might
maybe I'll just sell t-shirts that
wouldn't work yeah I mean why not what
happened to your neck in your profile
photo yeah fun story I had that phone
for almost a year and a half I was
having a dream that I was twisting off
this giant six-foot coke bottle cap and
I woke up in agony with my hands around
my my head I was twisting my own head
off yeah okay no I know this sounds like
a total lie but that actually happened
and and you hurt yourself I I hurt my
own I twisted my own neck in my sleep
you're trying to take your head off how
old were you when T five and then I went
to the doctor again they gave me x-rays
and stuff and the the doctor was looking
at my extra weird like there was
something wrong with it and then he he's
like Jonathan calls his other doctrine
now I'm really concerned they're looking
at my x-ray you wanted your on a doctor
confuse yeah as they're looking at your
ex because you woke up into pain yeah
like I knew I asked my neck up and they
were looking at my x-ray and he's he
looks back at me and I go is there
something wrong and he goes you have the
neck of a 7-foot man they just mean like
it's very long or I guess I have a long
neck 12 year old girls that give a
7-foot man he said yeah that was eight
he just want to let you know yeah and
that was it that was fine so the neck
brace you had to wear just to keep your
for that long well partly one Street I
don't it was my fault because I didn't
do the stretches and so it became like a
locked in a bad bit so I would keep
kinking it so I thought it was still
injured but really I just needed to
stretch then once I started stretching
that's fine well how long did it take
you from stretching to get that neck
brace like
a day like once I started to really
stretch hard and like work out the knot
I was fine but you had it on for like a
year
yeah on and off for a year though keep
kinking it cuz I never really got those
muscles to yeah they they go around the
injury when it first happens I mean they
lock in did you think after the year oh
I should have just stretched a year ago
I did and I wouldn't better do all that
yeah but I wouldn't have got that nice
photo actually that's true yeah you look
really crazy in that yeah that next
seven feet that's a long neck it is I
mean looking at it now your neck looks
long well I'm even crunching it like
really if I sit up straight I'm like
very I would have lower in our chair
they were the same height like I would
tower over you you're right I told you
five four okay you figure anyway but you
do have a long ya better be sitting down
right right you'd be the same height
your torsos are about the same but the
neck I never would have noticed until
you said so yeah I gotta crank it down
yeah what the shoulders up is that your
Hollywood neck when you want to try to
just like impress the industry and make
sure that they know they're just do an
et like what but I you know has long
necks regal people like the Kings long
them yeah they do the notorious for it
kings of countries being is breeding
king of social media yeah Instagram for
example show about I haven't seen it
honey read for it uh I wrote for the
first year that's actually why I started
doing Instagram I got like a midlife
crisis I gotta know like a writing loop
mm-hmm and I was like I want to I want
to make stuff you get into this - like
perform and then you're like in a writer
room which is not something I would pick
but I mean thankful for the job but but
her shows like it's a talk it's not a
talk show it's a little it's like a talk
show but there's like sketches here and
there it's political and she tries to
like blend Republicans and Democrat
tries to like you know smooth out the
tensions smooth out the kinks yeah yeah
yeah does it work so far everybody's
getting along again right so I guess it
must have been show yeah I mean
obviously working yeah yeah me so you
must have been like two parties like
latech technically there are more
parties there's nobody that we know you
gotta be what because it's just this
team mentality when you were in fifth
grade right you know Tommy was running
for class president it was just like if
I'm president we're gonna macaroni and
cheese every day for lunch and was again
if the teacher was like okay Tommy's up
he's a Democrat and half the class like
oh [ __ ] Tommy right it just we're not
even getting I don't know not too many
issues people people want it simplified
they're just like which side just all
the issues no you know everybody just
has to pick one thing and then that
explains how you feel about everything
we need one more one more party well we
tried one more party and then the guy
goes on TV and and they're like can you
name one other world leader and he said
no he was a [ __ ] you know Gary
Johnson right what a [ __ ] boob they
go who's another world leader and he's
like I don't know he knew her Aleppo was
I mean I don't know there's brought to
post in it you're not running for
president you dropped out of high school
what a [ __ ] boob right mmm right so
that's what happens is the one guy who's
stupid enough to run as a third-party
stupid yeah so we should any better guy
in there but then it you know you take
away votes from the other exactly yeah
that's as I said about uh
what's-his-name Ross Perot he took all
those votes away from Georgia he died
but he lost he kind of lost his mind at
the end he was doing great Ross Perot
yeah and then he James Stockdale is his
VP and just again an old guy of a smart
guy but just didn't talk well you know
you know what the issue is
we shouldn't have presidents anymore you
know what we should have a monarchy we
should have like a king yes yes thank
you don't you think next video how many
video yes yes they're always better yes
yeah please laughter to the people we
kind of do have a king actually right
now yeah yeah he's literally yesterday
saying you know well we maybe we should
do is have state-run media sure and that
works out well North Korea yeah exactly
yeah you might be right I think I think
he might be right so terrific do you do
the media do you put yourself on a
schedule of how often you have to put
out Instagram
I do two a week it's been slacking
lately I've been getting a little busy
doing other stuff yeah if you get to
like Wednesday show and there hasn't
been one if it gets to Wednesday and
there hasn't been a video you go and
like ah [ __ ] I didn't know ya I've not
got two and I've only got half a week
yeah yeah like right now I don't know
what what to write I said if I gotta
figure something out I feel like Trump
stuff feels bad I don't know people do
you do Amanda Bynes amanda Bynes his
back I got I gotta go home so I gotta
figure out what's talking about yeah try
to get an impression yeah she what is
she is she acting now or she just came
back and she's out of not doing drugs
announcing that she's not doing drugs
but then I ripped heartful I read the
whole article and she said that the
reason she was acting so crazy was
because she was smoking a lot of weed
and doing adderall yeah that'll do it
the kingdom binds us oh the King needs
to probably look that up amanda Bynes is
the king things he remembers she was on
some a kid show that's right and she
became a Hakeem's right the Kings right
okay good but I don't think her behavior
is explained by adderall and we think
that's right a little bit more going on
or something yeah I think a little bit
more knowing is hard it's hard to be a
person that's actually a good point it's
easy to be king you don't mental issues
do you I don't uh I don't
I had a bipolar uncle who everyone's
like you're just like your uncle Ricky
because he was musical and stuff like
that and then he killed himself and then
they stopped saying that to me we hope
you like how'd he kill himself he ran
into a train that's his car
men will really do it yeah no yeah
really do it wait winners quietly from
the south he ran like physically cars on
the tracks and a year later I was on the
same line you know it's the metro-north
and we hit a skunk and we were like ruin
High School look Oh gross and the
Canadian takes work you should have some
meld last year we hit this guy and I was
like I think that might have been my
uncle was probably
Wow ran head-on into a train yeah and
the
came to our house like all upset you
know it's upsetting yeah I mean if I
conducts a comedy show yeah what'd he
say
reignover he's saying it's like a song
and you prepare to go yeah usually I'm
very shy you play Jo train keeps on
coming I actually wasn't there he talked
my mom and apparently was very upset
obviously we really close to your uncle
onna I was but he was bipolar so I
didn't really connect on a too deep of a
level but we used to blow up stuff
together and he had a lot of
firecrackers and it was a fun I probably
there's so unpredicted said you just
don't know who you're getting like
they're really right they can be
wonderful moments yeah and also a lot of
more smartly he's brilliant you know
yeah I have a friend who's also bipolar
well I went to high school with it's
just a smartest guy and super fun when
it's like when it's a good time oh yeah
they're up all night they'd hit you it
like at 23 that's a thing that can be
completely normal and popular and smart
and then suddenly you're and then they
just spike up very high spike down very
low and we oh yeah every episode you
have the it gets worse and worse so your
first ones like kind of weird and then
you're talking to ducks and the next one
and then yeah yeah